les 52 américains sont libres ils ont
fêté terran à 18h24 ronald reagan
président l'amérique ne se soumettra
jamais assemblée générale des patrons la
situation économique n'est pas si
mauvaise soir de l'amérique qu'on se
soit un nouveau top 10 janvier en fin
d'après midi vous avez pu vivre en
direct l'investiture de ronald reagan et
l'annoncent dans nos bulletins spéciaux
de la libération des otages
cette petite dépêche que j'ai entre les
mains nous l'attendions depuis 444 jours
otages libérés les deux femmes et les 50
autres diplomates qui les accompagnaient
ont quitté téhéran à 17h24 très précises
heure de paris vous ne voyez donc avec
un raffinement très orientale l'iranien
honte
attendu que soit officiellement partie
jimmy carter un nouvel affront de plus
mais quel soulagement je sois en
amérique alors tout de suite le film
avec jack à bouchard de cette libération
assez poignante eu un film sans image
malheureusement car les iraniennes ne
nous ont pas envoyer l'image
oui on peut dire qu'ils attendaient ce
moment depuis 444 jours comme vous le
disiez les passagers d'un vol pas comme
les autres 10 ans le vol de la liberté
dès le décollage les 52 occupants
américains des deux avions algériens
n'étaient plus tout à fait des otages
ils redeviendront des sommes pleinement
libres lorsque les appareils auront
quitté définitivement l'espace aérien
iranien
ces appareils que nous voyons ce matin
qui était donc en bout de piste à
l'aéroport de mehrabad gare l'aéroport
international d'été en cette ultime
journée de leur captivité aura été
fertile en événements de tous genres des
difficultés de dernière heure avaient
même fait craindre un nouvel ajournement
l'espoir renaissait en fin de matinée
puis peu avant 3 heures cet après midi à
paris ont signalé une reprise de
l'activité autour des deux boeing
algérien qui était arrivé samedi à
téhéran
monsieur nabavi le ministre iranien
chargé
de l' affaire des otages se présentait
alors à l'aéroport en compagnie des
ambassadeurs d'algérie et de suisse
l'ambassadeur d'algérie compte tenu du
rôle joué un rôle d'intermédiaire joué
par son pays dans la négociation et l
ambassadeur de suisse parce qu'il
représente les intérêts américains à
terre enfin le départ des 52 otages
devenait une certitude il était
d'ailleurs confirmé officieusement à
partir de 17h30 puis la dépêche
comprenant ces deux simplement que
patrick poivre d'arvor vous a montré
otages libérés étaient lancés par l'
agence france-presse
à 18h30 heure française oui otages même
complètement libérés puisque normalement
donc ces otages ont quitté le territoire
le ciel aérien de l'iran ils doivent en
principe faire une escale technique très
rapide près d'athènes n'ont pas d'ankara
comme on l'avait cru avant d'arriver à
alger depuis une heure et demi donc il
nous faut nous efforcer de ne plus
parler d'otages mais je crois que ce
sera difficile même pour les 52
américains
on ne peut pas d'avoir traversé une
période de captivité d'un an et demi
sans restée traumatisée
en ce moment ils doivent se persuader
leur liberté ils ont donc je le répète
depuis quelques minutes quitté l'espace
aérien iranien
ils vont arriver dans trois heures
environ à alger alger où nous
retrouverons gérard ce badge arx back
par téléphone et non pas c'est dans la
nuit maintenant que les deux avions
d'air algérie en provenance de téhéran
atterriront sur l'aéroport de maison
blanche avec les 52 otages libre dans
cette formidable partie de poker que se
sont livrée américains et iraniens
il ne faut pas oublier le rôle
considérable joué par l'algérie s'est en
fait grâce à l'algérie que les positions
des deux parties ont pu se rapprocher un
effort diplomatique une conscience et un
savoir-faire à mettre au crédit des
négociateurs à therrien qui jusqu'à
dernier
minutes et dans le plus grand secret et
on sait qu'ils ont le goût du secret ont
joué avec ténacité ils ont insufflé la
volonté de réussir malgré les multiples
ornières qui se dressait devant eux les
obligeant parfois à reprendre les
négociations à zéro fierté chez les
algériens d'avoir réussi là où beaucoup
ont échoué
cette escale sur l'aéroport d'alger est
pour eux une grande victoire
ils ont fort bien compris et il compte
bien s'en servir plus tard
oui à washington toute la journée deux
hommes ont guetté plus que d'autres
minute par minute cette fameuse bonne
nouvelle qui viendrait de l'est et de
l'homme chimiques larter et ronald regan
se sont transmis le relais la présidence
américaine à 18 heures précises heure de
paris jusqu'au bout donc jimmy carter on
espérait bénéficier entre guillemets du
fruit intensive de ses efforts mais
l'histoire retiendra que la libération
ne se sera pas passée sous son mandat
pourtant on à régal bien d'avoir un
geste qui ne manque pas d'élégance on
vient d'apprendre qu'il avait décidé
d'envoyer jimmy carter walter mondale
son ancien vice-président donc et el
mundo ce qui sont anciens socata d'état
tous les trois à wiesbaden ce sont eux
qui officiellement représenteront les
états unis pour accueillir les otages
dès qu'ils auront transité par alger
alors en ce moment c'est la fête à
washington et dans tous les états unis
ont fait l'arrivée de reagan à la maison
blanche et la libération de 52 et ans
jacques séguy devrait être en ligne dure
alors cette fois ci est bien imager pas
son ça change un petit peu on est en
train de voir cette grande parade
je vais vous jack oui oui vous êtes à
l'entraînement aux yeux pas du capitole
enfin nous sommes pas loin on le voit
dans le sont effectivement on le voit
dans le fond donc en effet la parade à
tout petit peu de retard puis après je
dois parcourir les 2 km du capital que
vous voyez au fond de votre image pour
entrer à la maison blanche
et donc c'est attali naturellement sur
ces deux événements qui se sont passés à
dix villes qui
m intervalle il y a eu réaction à des
jeunes réaction le 40ème président des
états unis est entré est installée
maintenant mais le public américain n'a
pas encore réagi à la libération des
otages
pourquoi et bien c'est que je ne
mentirai pas en disant que la majorité
des américains se retrouvent en ce
moment devant les postes de télévision
et que les passes de télévision sont
occupées par les images que vous voyez
tels que vous avez vu il ya une heure au
moment de la prestation de serment de
ronald reagan et audi par le défilé des
familles d'otages que ce soit madame mon
fils tu à san diego que ça me saoule à
mme luisa kennedy au département d'état
il ya quelques instants
que ce soit madame colas à skis et que
vous avez vu hier soir tout
enfin disent qu'elles sont heureuses une
phrase banale naturellement mais que
peut-elle dire en ce moment elles ont
encore du mal à comprendre que le moment
que le jour j comme vous l'avez dit
après 444 jours est arrivé c'est
vraiment une journée exceptionnelle non
seulement marqué par une température
exceptionnelle plus 12 degrés pour
ronald reagan
il y avait des tempêtes de neige en 1960
pour jack kennedy
et puis on al ryyan remporte ainsi une
victoire car aujourd'hui c'est une
victoire pour lui qui est
l'aboutissement de 26 ans de démarches
politiques du jour ou en 1964 il avait
dit ils avaient parlé du grand rêve
qu'il poursuivait pour son pays
voilà à peu près ce qui arrivera pour
ronald reagan vous avez donné dans le
titre exactement ses intentions nous les
connaissons tous depuis depuis plusieurs
mois il veut redonner l'honneur et la
force économique dans la libre
entreprise à son pays
pour jimmy carter vous l'avez dit
également s'il vient de partir pour
faire une brève escale à plein et il
rentrera tout à l'heure à washington
pour partir ensuite à wiesbaden
mais il n'est pas exagéré de dire encore
en quelques mots quelle journée
sommes nous en train de vivre aux états
unis avec notamment une sale image pour
terminer chimie carter à 11h55 heure de
washington aux côtés de ronald reagan
na qui y est car ils pensaient jusqu'à
ce moment-là annoncé son écran de
télévision qu'il allait annoncer la
libération des otages et à la maison
blanche par la salle de presse
à 11h55 jeudi powell qui plaide trad et
à 12h05
un homme s'appelle la rythmique de
l'équipe reagan qui donne déjà des
informations sur les otages
la démocratie américaine fonctionne bien
elle a aujourd'hui à 40e président et
elle a retrouvé au champ d'honneur
puisque les otages sont libérés avoue
patrick oui alors que nous sommes comme
jacques saisis donc entrain attend de
cette parade qui est traditionnel après
l'élection et après l'investiture
officielle d'un président aux états unis
j'apprends que à berlin-ouest la cloche
de la liberté vient de sonner à l'hôtel
de ville de schoenberg c'est un cadeau
de la mecque aux allemands après le la
fin du blocus de berlin
alors il faut revenir je pense au film
chronologique de cette passation de
pouvoirs dont parlait jacques c'était
dans dans la douceur d'une matinée de
janvier on al rayan s'était rendu
auparavant dans une église il elle est
ensuite prêté serment et à recueillir
des mains de l'homme dont il avait
triomphé en novembre les intimes de
numéro 1 de l'exécutif un mec philippe
rochon six heures du soir à paris midi à
washington une température de 12 degrés
et un ciel bleu et un soleil éclatant
ronald et nancy reagan après la
bénédiction et la messe à l'église saint
john s'approche du chef de la cour
suprême le juge warren burger c'est
l'heure de la prestation de serment sur
la bible
ronald reagan devient ainsi le 40ème
président des états unis je jure
solennellement dit il que j'accomplirai
mon devoir de président des états-unis
et que je préserverai protégerai et
défendrai la constitution dans la mesure
de mes moyens
que dieu me vienne en aide
ronald et nancy reagan ému presque
jusqu'aux larmes souri aux dizaines de
milliers de sympathisants qui ont envahi
la capitale américaine
alors que l'on tire la salle d'honneur
demanda de jimmy carter est ainsi
terminée
le démocrate passe le pouvoir pour
républicains alors qu'à téhéran les
cinquante deux otages libérés sont déjà
dans l'avion et une certaine amertume se
lit sur le visage de celui qu'on
appellera maintenant l'ex président
carter
et puis c'est le discours de ronald
reagan un discours d'un quart d'heure il
a écrit lui-même à la main un discours
essentiellement consacré à la situation
économique et à la défense des états
unis
on en retiendra des phrases très ferme
l'amérique ne se soumettra jamais aucune
arme au monde
il est aussi puissante que la liberté
c'est une arme que nos ennemis ne
possède pas mais que nous avons nous les
américains nous avons les moyens a dit
ronald reagan
tout comme dans le passé de conserver
cette forteresse de la liberté que nous
sommes il faut réveiller le géant
industriel américain
et pour cela il n'y aura pas de
compromis il faut remettre l'amérique au
travail
nous ne sommes pas condamnés au déclin
nous commençons une ère de renouveau
national il y a encore des héros à l'
usine au travail dans les familles et
c'est à eux que je m'adresse chaque
américain est un héros c'est cela
l'amérique
et puis c'est la photo de famille à
droite
madame et monsieur george bush vice
président des états unis à gauche nancy
et ronald reagan
depuis deux heures maintenant les plus
hautes personnalités d'amérique et pour
saluer l'inauguration du mandat de
ronald reagan c'est cette femme mère de
cinq enfants croient ni à burger qui a
été choisie pour chanter l'hymne
national dédié au 40ème président des
états unis
mise en scène traditionnelle aux démunis
en ce moment dans un petit peu partout
dans les salles de bal en europe
d'ailleurs comme aux états unis pour les
citoyens américains n'a pas georges
bortoli examinons un petit peu le
premier discours de président élu de
ronald regan d'un discours qui
n'apportent pas de révélations mais qui
donne quand même un ton absolument
discours ou nom est khan a repris les
grands thèmes sa campagne électorale
on n'attendait pas évidemment qu'ils
ouvrent les dossiers d'abord parce que
ça n'est pas la loi du genre n'ouvre pas
les dossiers comme ça au cours d'un
discours d'inauguration entre une prière
et à l'hymne national et puis monsieur
rien ne sera peut-être pas tellement
l'homme des dossiers contrairement à
carter qui connaissait très bien les
dossiers mais qui hésite et sur les
conclusions à tirer lui laissera le
comment dirais-je les affaires précise à
son équipe et il veut être surtout le
leader peut être un homme un peu
charismatique si vous voulez une
certaine incarnation d'une amérique
moyenne et tout son discours ça a été ça
la fierté nationale qui expliquent le
vague en somme de toute la partie de
politique étrangère où il n'ya presque
rien
baho qu'une chose précise une bonne
parole pour les alliés une menace pour
les ennemis potentiels
et puis de nouveau lié à la fierté des
hommes libres au fond toute cette
cérémonie ça a été unanime à l'américain
les américains une certaine amérique
c'est pas tout l'american est axé plus
compliqué que ça mais en tout cas une
certaine amérique l'amérique moyenne
c'est applaudi en la personne de reggane
dans ses bronzes in le patriote est
chanté par les soldats chamarrés et puis
elle céda bloody dans ce pasteur musclé
qui présidait les cérémonies religieuses
la prière et qui semblait sorti d'un
western
bref tout ça était conforme à ce qu'on
attendait et monsieur régalons indique
monsieur reagan était un cowboy au fond
c'était aussi sa force il faut peut-être
pas un sourire prêt avant même
l'investiture officielle du 40ème
président américain des messages de
félicitations du monde entier affluent
et à la maison blanche parmi les
premiers le roi hussein de jordanie le
premier ministre chinois le président de
taïwan
le chef de l'état français dont joignons
patricia phare de l'aiea
l'élysée pour ses réactions françaises
le président carter a donc adressé dès
hier une lettre à valérie giscard
d'estaing pour lui annoncer qu'un accord
avait été conclu
je veux que vous soyez élu écrit-il l'un
des premiers à être remercier pour votre
magnifique coopération au cours de la
très difficiles années que nous venons
de connaître les américains se
souviendront toujours de la manière dont
le gouvernement et le peuple français
sont restés si résolument à leurs côtés
tout au long de cette épreuve
aujourd'hui valéry giscard d'estaing dès
qu'il a appris l'annoncé officielle de
la libération à son tour et créative me
carter pour le féliciter le président de
la république a également adressé un
message à madame louise à kennedy
la femme d'un des détenus un diplomate
américain la question qui reste posée ce
soir c'est celle des sanctions que la
communauté économique européenne et la
france en particulier avait prises à
l'égard de l'iran des sanctions
économiques
et bien cette question sera
vraisemblablement abordée dès demain en
conseil des ministres ont fait remarquer
ce soir à l'elysée qu'il ya toutes les
raisons pour lever ces sanctions
on peut même dire d'ordonner la patricia
que les mini des labels trangères de la
communauté européenne qui étaient réunis
aujourd'hui à bruxelles viennent à
l'instant de se féliciter la libération
des 52 américains et ils ont annoncé que
les décisions diplomatiques et
économiques décidées donc contre l'iran
en avril dernier à luxembourg n'était
plus nécessaire donc précédant de peu
jimmy carter valter monde et les menaces
qui l'ancien saccades adultes américains
ça risque même c'est une trentaine
d'experts américains viennent de quitter
washington à destination de francfort
pour y retrouver les ex otages qui
auront transité dans la nuit par alger
viendront ensuite pour ces hommes et ces
femmes un repos de quelques jours
accompagné d'examens médicaux intensifs
examen nécessité bien sûr par cette très
longue captivité 444 jours
aux cris d' occupons ce nid d'espions
400 étudiants se ruent à l'intérieur de
l'ambassade américaine de terre en ce
dimanche 4 novembre 1979 la révolution
islamique vit sa prise de la bastille
quelques diplomates les yeux bandés sont
présentés aux milliers de personnes
aussitôt après le spectacle insoutenable
pour l'amérique
humilié à new york on brûle et on
piétine les portraits de commenee
première riposte de carter l'argent
iranien déposés dans les banques
américaines est gelé c'est à dire
bloqués tehran relève le défi ce sera le
chat contre les otages
l'iran réclame l'extradition du
souverain qui est hospitalisé à new york
à la grande prière du vendredi à téhéran
le nom de carter est traîné dans la boue
on lance les premiers slogans contre le
grand satan de la maison blanche
les nations unies sans mal pour réclamer
la libération immédiate de tous les
diplomates comme eni fait un geste et
renvoie chez eux
18 des séquestrés de l'ambassade dont
cinq femmes et si noir
ils sont libres ils se congratulent eux
n'auront pourtant vécu que 16 jours de
détention les appâts la ville est
souverain et la principale victime de la
sphère déjà profondément marqué par la
maladie il est contraint de quitter les
états unis et se rend à panama avec sa
famille ce n'est qu'une première étape
jugé rapidement
indésirable à panama il devra s'exiler
au caire le conseil de sécurité revient
à la charge et envoie monsieur kurt
valdaï mme à téhéran c'est un échec
complet
le secrétaire général de l'onu échappe
même de justesse un attentat on lui
reproche ses relations passées avec la
famille pas la vie
après quatre mois de détention la
télévision iranienne diffuse les
premières images des otages
il semble en bonne santé l'amérique est
rassuré mais le sentiment d'exaspération
2000 carter donne un nouveau tour de vis
ils avaient décrété l'embargo économique
contre l'iran il rompt les relations
diplomatiques 25 avril 1980 celle
escalade avec un raid de commandos lancé
pour libérer les otages
il tourne au désastre dans le désert
iranien plusieurs hélicoptères sont mis
hors d'usagé abandonnés surtout huit
soldats américains ont péri dans
l'opération
teheran réplique en annonçant la
dispersion des otages dans différentes
villes du pays
l'un d'entre eux le vice-consul richarde
queen retrouvera l'amérique dans les
semaines qui suivent les iraniens juge
son état de santé alarmant les
diplomates détenus sont alors au nombre
de 52
un moment on pense que la mort de reza
pahlavi le 27 juillet au caire va
accélérer le dénouement de la faire il
n'en est rien l'ayatollah khomeini pose
4 conditions dont deux sont draconiennes
retour des biens du char et déblocage
des fonds iraniens déposés dans les
banques américaines
la premier dialogue s'engage pourtant
avec le voyage à new york de monsieur
rajaï aux nations unies le premier
ministre iranien dénonce les exactions
du régime du shah et exhibe son pied
mutilé par les tortionnaires de
l'ancienne police secrète
lorsque la guerre éclate entre l'irak et
l'iran
l' affaire des otages d'abord relégué au
second plan relance de nouvelles
spéculations
téhéran dit on est tributaire des états
unis pour son armement ces pièces de
rechange
ces munitions
alors
alors comme eni n'accepte aucun
marchandage
le parlement iranien confirme les
conditions posées par l'ayatollah et les
tractations se poursuivre entre téhéran
et washington
par l'intermédiaire de l'algérie
l'équipe carter fait le forcing à la
proche de l'élection présidentielle du 4
novembre
en vain malgré sa défaite le président
sortant ne désespère pas d'obtenir une
libération avant de quitter la maison
blanche le 20 janvier
il le dit aux journalistes en se gardant
de tout pronostic optimiste
nous essayons du team de trouver une
issue honorable à la fois pour l'iran et
pour la mairie jimmy carter délègue à
alger le numéro deux du département
d'état
monsieur warren christopher pour les
ultimes tractations
après une semaine de marchandage et de
discussions serrées l'accord est enfin
annoncée les otages viennent de passer
le cap des 4 140 jours de détention
et 80 44 exactement je crois qu'on se
souviendra longtemps de ce chiffre en ce
moment donc les otages sont dans l'avion
il devrait atterrir dans peu de temps
pour une escale technique à près
d'athènes puis à alger à ce moment-là
transfert ils ne prendront plus les
appareils d'air algérie dans lequel il
était jusqu'à lors mais ceux de l'armée
de l'air américaine qui est qui sera
venu lécher qui seront venus les
chercher de wiesbaden et qui les
reconduire ont tout de suite en
allemagne de l'ouest on ne pense pas que
ces appareils puissent arriver avant 5 6
heures du matin ce soir tout ce que nous
pouvions dire de cet heureux dénouement
glas tout moment évidemment soin de
washington avec jacques s'est dit soit
deux terrans d'alger où d'ailleurs avec
tous nos correspondants le monde et
toute cette réaction qui s'est mobilisée
pendant 48 heures nous pourrons
intervenir dans le courant de ce journal
la seule autre information notable en
provenance de l'étranger vient ce soir
de varsovie le syndicat solidarité a
maintenu son mot d'ordre de grève pour
après-demain jeudi à gdansk grève
d'avertissement de quatre heures en
france
économie politique avec cette
déclaration de raymond barre devant la
presse étrangère dans les semestres à
venir la france 2010 connaîtra une
décélération des prix quant à son avenir
personnel le premier ministre a été on
ne peut plus allusif écoutez plutôt
cette bret la seule chose que je puisse
vous dire quant à l'avenir on ce qui me
concerne c'est cette formule bien connue
toujours l'inattendu arrive et je me
borne à attendre l'inattendu
on verra bien une déclaration très dur
de georges marchais aujourd'hui le
numéro 1 du pc candidat à l'élection
présidentielle venait protester contre
l'annulation des inscriptions sur les
listes électorales dans plusieurs
municipalités tenus par son parti
l'occasion pour lui de dénoncer très
vigoureusement la politique dit que la
coupe est pleine et que la machination
ourdie par monsieur giscard d'estaing
contre l'inscription d'un millier de
travailleurs sur les listes électorales
dans les mairies communistes l'a fait
déborder jeudi assez de la république
des châteaux et des cadeaux de l'état
des cousins et des copains du clan des
chers parents et des princes
monsieur giscard d'estaing agit bien
dans la ligne d'une famille qui a
toujours combattu à l'extrême droite la
classe ouvrière la démocratie la nation
dossiers économiques
le nombre des faillites a augmenté de
près de 10% l'année dernière je parle en
fait de toutes les entreprises
défaillantes qu'elle soit en règlement
judiciaire en liquidation de biens ou en
faillite proprement libre pourtant le
cnpf est plutôt relativement optimiste
quant à la conjoncture des mois à venir
la france a des atouts considérables a
dit françois ceyrac qui préside
aujourd'hui l'assemblée générale
annuelle de son conseil national
philippe sassier certains aveyron un
symbole dans le fait que cette assemblée
du cnpf se soit tenue dans les salons du
nom de everest
mais au moment où la bourse se fait
grise mine ou
le déficit du commerce extérieur bat des
records où tout le monde s'accorde pour
dire que là dès 1981 sera une année
difficile les 500 patrons qui étaient
réunis ce matin n'ont pas voulu regarder
les 12 mois qui viennent avec des
lunettes noires d'abord il ne s'agit pas
de refroidir le moral des troupes
un patron qui a peur du lendemain
n'investit pas ensuite les patrons
estiment que si la france paie un lourd
tribut à la crise avec le chômage elle
garde des atouts notamment en hommes et
en technologie est qu'elle a gardé son
rang parmi les grandes puissances
économiques internationales
il s'agit donc pour la france dit ces
mêmes patrons d'attaqué et non pas
d'aller se réfugier dans une tranchée
sans fond s'enfoncer dans une transe et
cela veut dire renoncer à attaquer
attendre la tacc de l'adversaire
échapper aux coups et prendre une
attitude défensive ça conduit finalement
je dirais à la mort ou à la prison
on a toujours vu comme ça la deuxième
formule est ce celle qui permet de
gagner les guerres c'est la manne heures
c'est la guerre de mouvement avec ça
signifie qu dans les mois qui viennent
il faudrait prendre des mesures de
relance pour aider à ce redéploiement à
ces manoeuvres
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas nous
avons actuellement un certain nombre
d'atouts d'atouts financier avec la de
1,6 mo d'atouts technologiques
il faut développer la recherche bien sûr
mais surtout je dirais il faut prendre
un attitude innovatrices qui pour ce
mouvement qu'est ce que vous pourriez
demander au prochain gouvernement qui
sera issu des prochaines élections
présidentielles pour l'instant la
sagesse consiste à compter d'abord sur
nos propres forces et nous avons la
possibilité actuellement de façade entre
deux choses nous verrons plus tard
puisque vous abandonner la présidence du
cnpf la fin de cette année monsieur le
président quel genre d'homme pouvait
vous voir comme votre remplaçant
surtout pas un homme comme moi il faut
savoir changer la guerre de la baguette
16 boulanger en grève à givors dans le
rhône pour protester contre elle
vente des baguettes un franc dans un
grand magasin de la ville
la grève de la sncf et bien je termine
cette nuit le trafic sera tout à fait
normal demain plus de 1000 licenciements
dans l'électronique précisément à la
radio technique et ce à la suite d'un
plan de restructuration de l'entreprise
enfin un cri d'alarmé des professionnels
du textile attention distille nous
prévoyons cent mille suppressions
d'emplois dans les trois ans à venir si
rien n'est fait d'ici là jean claude
renaud aujourd'hui ce sans vêtements
vendus en france 43 viennent de
l'étranger pour certains articles comme
des pull over ou les chemises
c'est beaucoup plus de la moitié mais ce
sont surtout les importations en
provenance de l'asie du maghreb et des
pays de l'est qui donne des cauchemars
aux industriels de l'habillement elles
envahissent de plus en plus le marché
français disent ils
elle provoque chez nous les peaux de
bilan et licencient le secteur de
l'habillement a perdu 18 mille emplois
de 77 à 79 13 milles en 1981 et il
pourrait en perdre cent mille en quatre
ans si l'invasion des produits importés
se poursuit nous ne luttons pas à armes
égales disent les industriels français
un ouvrier chinois coûte 30 fois moins
cher que la couturière française
et si les costumes d'hong kong les
chevilles de taïwan où les jeans de
tunisie delphi toute concurrence
c'est grâce à une main d'oeuvre sous
payée et exploiter
c'est pourquoi les professionnels
demandent au gouvernement un véritable
plan anti crise en réalité nous
proposons aujourd'hui aux pouvoirs
publics de mettre en oeuvre une nouvelle
politique qui tranche avec celle qui a
été menée jusqu'à présent une politique
articulée autour de quatre idées
centrales
premièrement freiner les importations
qui envahissent aujourd'hui notre marché
de manière excessive
deuxièmement moraliser les échanges
internationaux c'est-à-dire faire
respecter par tous les règles du jeu
inscrits dans les accords stimuler
les exportations qui demeure le moteur
de notre industrie et enfin réformé des
réglementations sociales et fiscales qui
nous paraissent totalement inadapté à la
situation présente le plan textile du
gouvernement est insuffisant selon les
industriels de l'habillement ils veulent
que les importations ont évolué en
fonction de la consommation qui diminue
sinon distille il faudra appliquer
l'article 19 du gatt c'est-à-dire
bloquer purement et simplement les
importations opération de police ce
matin long oui contre la radio de la cgc
la cgt pardon radio lorraine coeur
d'acier
plusieurs centaines de crs de policiers
et de gardes mobiles ont investi la
mairie là où se trouvaient les émetteurs
et bien malgré cette intervention
massive
la radio a repris ses émissions il y a
deux heures et demie la cgt accuse la
ratp la direction l'atp elle lui fait
supporter l'entière responsabilité de
l'accident du rer d'hier soir à la
station auber c'est à cause d'un nouveau
système de signalisation dit-elle
réponse à l'instant de la direction de
la ratp
c'est pas possible parce que l'intéressé
c'est à dire le conducteur de la machine
qui a tamponné l'autre machine avait
assuré depuis le 17 janvier c'est à dire
le jour de la mise en place de ce
nouveau signal avait assuré son service
donc il devait être au courant de cette
nouvelle signalisation alors une
information contre x a été ouverte
d'après midi par le parquet de paris et
laurent massardier est allé voir sur
place comment fonctionnait le dispositif
de sécurité sur le réseau du rer
la première des mesures de sécurité sur
le réseau passe tout d'abord par la
signalisation feux verts ou à libre
rouge stop jaune ralentir ces signaux
sont commandés en fonction d'un
programme précis de circulation établi
en avance et tenant compte aussi de
l'écoulement même du trafic
ainsi par exemple lorsqu'une rame qui
est une station le signal passe
automatiquement rouge bloquant ainsi le
convoi suivant et si le signal n'est pas
respectée il y as blocage automatique
des freins comme dispositif de sécurité
vous avez ici la veille qui est actionné
par un cercle au alors c'est quoi la
veille
la veille c'est un dispositif qui lui
permet d'arrêter le train lorsqu'on
actionne pas le
le cercle oh oui ou alors si on
n'intervient pas sur une [ __ ] vous
avez ici une au pénal qui fait fonction
de veille aussi
c'est à dire que si on lâche la veille
le temps va s'arrêter quelques secondes
après vous allez entendre une sectionné
authentique voiliers et l'autre à
s'arrêter quelques secondes après
services de sécurité
alors pour repartir il faut annuler la
veille que nous avons le départ à
l'entrée de la gare on
130 km parce que nous avons encore une
distance de 200 mètres pour arrêter les
larges noir signalisations et systèmes
de freinage sont donc au coeur de l'anc
est théoriquement toutes les mesures en
place devrait rendre l'accident
impossible et pourtant hier soir à la
station auber l'impossible s'est produit
autre sécurité encore le conducteur qui
est seul dans la motrice n'est jamais
livré à lui même il est en relation
permanente par liaison téléphonique
directe avec le poste de commande
centralisé à 77,15 départ de val de
fontenay lé tout me reçoit toujours en
définitive que les responsabilités soit
humaine ou mécanique
seule l'analyse de la boîte noire qui
équipe chaque rame et enregistre seconde
après seconde
toutes les données du parcours pourra le
déterminer de façon formelle voilà la
ferme de breuil alors que le canard
enchaîné fait savoir que la brigade anti
gang était au courant des menaces de
mort pesant sur jean de braye à l'appui
de deux déclarations de policiers est
bien la commission parlementaire chargée
d'examiner le rôle de michel pipe de ski
alors ministre de l'intérieur vient de
tenir une réunion je pense que à 23h
23h30 dans le dernier journal et avait
claude daniel brême sera en mesure de
nous donner des précisions
nous terminons donc ce journal avec un
rappel de cette folle journée à
washington et à téhéran alors que
toujours derrière moi
vous voyez le capitole dans le lointain
avec le passage de la future parade qui
en général accompagnées toujours ce
genre de l'investiture du président
américain
pour rappel donc que les otages sont
libérés depuis 18h27 très précises puis
1h30 donc ils sont dans l'avion
leur avion a même quitté le ciel à
l'espace aérien iranien
il est pris en charge par la tour de
contrôle d'ankara me dit on ce qu'il
laisserait peut être entendre qu'ils
s'arrêteraient rancart et non pas à
athènes j'ai appris par ailleurs par le
diplomate suisse qui les a accompagnés
qui les a vus à bord de l'avion qu'ils
étaient tous en bonne santé mais
évidemment extrêmement fatigué il
devrait arriver à francfort pas avant 5
6 heures du matin et valéry giscard
d'estaing vient à l'instant de remercier
le président publique algérienne pour le
rôle qu'a joué l'algérie dans cette
douloureuse affaire qui est donc depuis
ce soir terminé voilà nous terminons
nous quant à nous avec évidemment la
météo très rapidement vous découvrez
qu'il faisait extrêmement
aujourd'hui pour la saison et que pour
demain et bien le temps restera doux et
humide sur l'ouest sur les autres
régions il fera froid avec alternance
d'éclaircies et de passages nuageux
ceux ci donneront des chutes de neige
sur le nord-est ainsi que sur les
pyrénées sur les massifs montagneux les
récentes chutes de neige abondantes
maintiennent de gros risques et nous le
répétons de gros risque d'avalanche
voilà ce journal est terminée à 23h30
donc avec lola fallait dossiers de
l'écran fera le point de cette actualité
extrêmement chargée en ce moment et puis
demain à 12h45
vous retrouverez patrick lecocq bonsoir
à tous